[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les âmes sensibles sur le bouton
[Musique]
c'est un drame déchirant
j'ai vécu parfois en lisant dans les
journaux les aventures extraordinaires
de ce qui se trouve dans le no man's
land d'un vieux bar désert avec tous les
poulets au dessus j'ai mal au cul et eau
saft
que je
on se marre
hugo
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
allah
ça fait
je peux
les jambes cherche des cros g
[Musique]
dans ta gueule
paris
là haut
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arthur
jeu 7 flicaille
ça change d'âme
carton
ban ki moon
personne
je bosse avec
[Musique]
et
les
cela lui
tu veux te lei
[Musique]
ans
à
[Musique]
m
sue takada redire
il m'a paru
le film
m
je ne veux pas
tu recevras 7
tepa
[Musique]
bgi
fini aussi à mi mai
gros
[Applaudissements]
tél
où j'ai bloqué
[Musique]
une petite croisière
le nom à tous
oui
tous
[Musique]
m
non
bah
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
m
du coup
non je ne sais plus
[Musique]
chaque fille
j'ai lancé m
mais la poule
tous les mêmes
qui flippe et d'entrer je dirais tu l'as
pas vu passer mec
et comme ce tabou ultime répond kiss
que tout avec moi
[Musique]
ans
oui
[Musique]
oui je n'ai pas la d61 cars 2 je fais un
malheur
je suis
oui
non
[Musique]
elle a au fond du bal
qui noie son chagrin
[Applaudissements]
quand elle voit ce mec qui courent
en tout cas l'air tel monde quel monde
perdu
[Musique]
tellement perdu
qu'elle demande pas trop écoute
qu'est ce qu'il veut ce mec qu'est ce
qu'il a il était pas si timide quand il
était petit maintenant regarde ce qu'il
est devenu
je savais ce qui pose son chapeau sur la
caméra et regarde dans quel état
issoufou avec tout ce qu'il a avalé je
les connais ils couraient parmi les
chants d'oiseaux une fleur il était
frérot comme un prince on regarde
comment il est maintenant maman
aujourd'hui pas fabien entrée de la
messe parce que c'est dimanche ou du
bistrot et regardant que l'état essaie
me cissé pour moi je veux bien lui à
faire quelque chose pour lui qu'elle dit
la vieille dié vieille [ __ ] et à ce
moment là le patron qui jean tendance
dure ancien de n'importe quoi anciens
d'un peu de tout qui est revenu tout et
qui n'ira plus jamais nulle part vu
qu'il est déjà revenu tout aux deux gros
battoir sur le rebord du comptoir et
dire la petite fuite est un cube dégâts
retourne au bar bible 7
c'est plus
oui
hu
[Musique]
m
ce qu'à dieu
direct c'est que tu peux slip et
s'asseoir
si je serai ce cas je ferai sûrement
non
te dirait de la lors du match que tu
avec ce maillot
as tu as tout ce que tu veux
je vais mais km h
tu va beaucoup trop loin
est ce que t'as pas quand je sais pas ce
que tu veux
avec judas y en a qui se
moi j'ai pour toi c'est trop peu c'est
déjà pour que pour moi tu as tout ce que
tu peux me com
[Applaudissements]
je sens que tu veux
[Musique]
je crois que tu va beaucoup trop loin
[Applaudissements]
ce 100 m de là
non
[Musique]
là
photo
ça veut dire c'est l'hiver bientôt quand
les photographes reviennent ce qui m'a
fait beaucoup plus froid
enfin je veux dire ce qu'on trouve pas
sur les plages quant à moi je suis qu'un
genre de loup solitaire
[Musique]
chagrin ce qui est et leur mère vraiment
quand j'ai rien à me mettre sous la dent
je grimpe dans un wagon restaurant
elle a une bonne douzaine de rangs bière
les grosses qui se tape une vieille
partie de poker
jambon à l'os 3 par la portière elle
l'autre suivant
chantant we
et contrôleurs et rentre dedans
[Musique]
j'apprécie pas ses manières j plan de
mes crocs sa visière
[Musique]
seul permis
le ciel grâce tombe de la bruine
j'ai le moral qui tombe en ruine
légionnaire de kata oui
brassée de me casser la gueule
bourg et d'assassins de contrô le de
fonctionner
pauvre gosse qu'un gros chèque
vient de s'allonger sous
parti de rien comme un vrai sauna
tu as toutes les charges
nulle part
sur les gammes
ce soit tout serait dans
[Musique]
il a beau être qu'un loup solitaire
elles font du caractère blade y avait
quelqu'un les soirs d'hiver
et du fil une méchante envie de chialer
[Musique]
surtout quand le dernier bus la largue
jusqu'au petit matin
[Musique]
je paye plus
qui avez-vous à des clashs dans ce grand
instant pathétique quand plus personne
crache sur le fric
patron tu peux et j'espère
de l'autre côté de la barrière
pareil quand dieu s'est flingué
[Musique]
après que dans la misère
et est un loup pour son frère
ce qu'on l'avait pas trop l'air de l'eau
mouais
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
si je te raconte tout ça ce soir c'est
que j'ai chopé un vieux coup cafards
mais je pense pas autre chose à faire
bah vrai qu'à écouter les loups
solidaire déconner c'est le
[Rires]
[Musique]
par les poubelles
hockey hebdo
[Musique]
à
paris/new york new york paris
oui
com
pour contout seul à
[Applaudissements]
j'attends ma petite sujet car il parle
16h33
tous droits
du
dames
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je peux pas
[Musique]
exclusif à une longueur
à créer une bombe
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'au toit
je suis tant à a
moi je suis déjà
paquet
tiens
et
[Musique]
ban
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]